[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the data science hangout
for anybody joining for the first time
I'm Rachel this is an open space for the
whole data science Community to connect
and chat about data Science Leadership
questions you're facing and get to learn
a little bit about what's going on in
the world of data science across
different Industries too
and so these sessions are recorded and
shared to the rstudio YouTube so you can
always go back and re-watch or find
helpful resources or share with one of
your colleagues as well
feel free to always share this invite if
there's someone across your team that
you think May benefit from joining in
the conversations too
we do also have a LinkedIn group if you
want to connect with people after the
fact it can be a little bit easier to
find each other in there or continue
conversations
I'm sure someone from our team will
share it in just a second in the chat
here
but together we're all dedicated to
creating this welcoming environment here
for everybody so we love when everyone
can participate and we can hear from you
all so no matter your level of
experience or area of work
there's three ways that you can ask
questions and we'll remind you of this
in the chat too but you can jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom here
and I'll just call on you you can put
your questions in the zoom chat and feel
free to just put a little star next to
it if you prefer that I read it out loud
if like your dog's barking or you're in
a coffee shop or something
um and then third we also have a slider
link where you can ask questions
anonymously and I see Tyler just share
that in the chat right now
I I want to keep adding this I always
frame this as questions but if you also
have something to add to a specific
topic
um feel free to use those options too or
raise your hand and jump in the
conversation as well to share your
perspective
but I am so excited to be joined by my
co-host here today Jesse Pluto senior
manager of ebi strategic analytics at
Comcast
and Jesse I'd love to have you jump in
to introduce yourself and share a little
bit about your role and
maybe something fun that you like to do
outside of work too
sure welcome everyone I'm pretty excited
to be here
um as Rachel mentioned I am Jesse Pluto
I'm a senior manager here at Comcast I
work in our Enterprise business
intelligence Department
um in strategic analytics and my focus
is really on video and content and a big
part of my job I've been here for almost
five years and my goal every year has
remained pretty consistent every year I
am really trying to save on the
programming costs so you know as
companies like you know keep going
through mergers Viacom CDs you know
comes Paramount and these companies
become bigger and bigger they're losing
advertising Revenue they're gaining some
you know a little bit of
um Power in kind of the negotiations for
how much they want to charge us for
programming which we unfortunately have
to offset to the customer
um programming cost is the largest cost
that Comcast has
um it's outpaced even labor and so
really I am trying to save you know a
couple hundred million dollars here a
couple hundred million dollars there you
know no big deal get to those bees every
once in a while and that's kind of been
my main focus I actually have a
background I studied psychology and
undergrad in undergrad which is why I
think I really like the behavioral part
of this job looking at you know customer
Behavior trying to figure out like what
programs do people really care about
what would people do if they didn't have
this programming
and
um really I kind of said it's like in
undergrad I did a master certificate in
applied statistics afterwards got my
foot in the door in a GIS job
um trying to do some like Market uh
research around like where can companies
franchise restaurants really open up a
new location that would impact sales to
the existing markets worked for a brief
period at a pharmaceutical research
company before I came here to buy um
here to Comcast for the last four and a
half five years
that's awesome so casual save 100
million dollars here and there hey there
you know no big deal yeah that's cool
um one part of that that question is
tell us something fun that you like to
do in your free time too
pretty basic stuff I like to go hiking I
love to get outside I live here in
Center City Philadelphia so I do love to
just get outside the city get to a
national park you know lose that cell
service you lose the Wi-Fi and just go
hiking for a couple days or a week here
and there nice that's great I always
love seeing the pictures from our team
when they go hiking and put them in like
the slack channel to share with
everybody
oh yeah that's what I love off of
so I know when we were chatting briefly
ahead of of the call you mentioned you
trans transition into people management
a little less than a year ago but I've
been thinking a lot about team building
community building and being purposeful
about culture so I'd love to kick off
the conversation with that while we wait
for some questions to come in too
about creating a sense of community like
how do you do that
um I work very very briefly in our
restaurants
um in the front of house and realized
that I was a little bit more comfortable
in the back of house but I did I
understand the idea of like the touch
and and you know I did do customer
service for many years before I
transitioned to analytics so I really
feel like I kind of like took a lot of
that where it's okay like what are the
you know little things that I can do to
try to you know be intentional about
like what is the culture that I want to
create here for my team
um I do have the advantage of coming
from a I had a manager before I got you
know went into people management who was
just like an exceptional manager in
terms of creating a culture that I
really wanted to kind of almost
replicate and it's you know very it's a
lot easier to kind of like borrow than
it is to create something from scratch
and so I really they borrowed a lot from
some of my previous managers one of my
big you know principles again that I
have borrowed from previous managers is
this idea of one recognizing false
deadlines and not necessarily
trying to hit these false deadlines if
it's not necessarily something that's
going to make a business impact if it's
not a business decision being made at a
specific date really kind of giving some
flexibility to my team to
you know where there is value investing
the time
um so that's one and then just really
like borrow often share freely you know
take code that's out there share code
with other people see how somebody else
has done something in the past and
really try to kind of Leverage what's
already been done out there I think
that's been really helpful for you know
just kind of like
building like a collaborative culture
where it's like okay we may have done
something for the first time but we
borrowed this part of it so like let's
give a shout out to this person you know
let's put our code on GitHub let's go
around to other team members and just
kind of share what we did why we did it
what kind of we learned throughout the
process sharing that pretty frequently I
think just kind of allows us to kind of
you know just be open to this idea of
collaboration I don't I might own this
project but you know there's no reason
to be possessive of knowledge let's
share that as often as we can and that's
something that I borrowed too from the
rstudio community
um just growing up in that Community
well not growing up but you know
learning
um getting into analytics in that
Community has been just such a great
learning experience for what works
um and then really it's just kind of
like doing I think like you said like
those touch-ins and trying to make sure
that I have frequent you know
check-ins with my team and see like okay
how are you doing are you stuck on
anything do you need help it can be very
very difficult honestly especially when
you get a new team and you're trying to
transition out of doing the Hands-On
work yourself this is one of the things
I struggled with the most is making time
for you know the people on my team who
need feedback who needs to be moving
forward to be successful and sometimes
that is at the expense of okay I can't
do my own code that needs to get done
but this is the right thing to invest my
time in right now is making sure that
they can move forward and that they have
what they need that they are getting
frequent feedback and exposure and all
of those things so just kind of
you know making sure that they have what
they need and letting go of some of the
you know way that I have done things for
you know a few years
I agree with the Javier in the chat too
I love that like no reason to be
possessive of knowledge across teams as
well
and so you mentioned like making time
for
the individuals that on your team to
give them feedback they do have to like
structure certain like office hours or
how do you handle that
so I do have scheduled one-on-ones every
week on Monday with my team you know
both down and upwards
um just so that we can like make sure
that we hit the ground running on Friday
I'm sorry on Monday and then throughout
the week we have a couple of other team
meetings you know like where we meet as
a group not necessarily one-on-ones but
you know I think during coven one of the
things that we got used to you know
working from home is just the idea of
okay we don't necessarily need to have
time on our calendar you know we don't
need a daily stand-up on my team but we
need some sort of daily check-in where
it's like okay do you have what you need
part of it is honestly just making sure
that I am available that I have time on
my calendar that I'm not completely
overbooked to the point where if my team
needs some feedback that I am not
available for two days that's not a good
way to work and so some of it as long as
they're just blogging out some time on
my calendar and making sure that I have
time every day that I can be available
and
if I'm not making sure that
basically like when my team reaches out
if they have a question that I am being
responsive and kind of setting an
example of I am going to make time for
you when you need time and everything
else I'll push aside all the
responsibilities other meetings I can
move those around to make sure that you
know I am prioritizing you and your
success and I think it can be very you
know um you know I do like mentorship
program for like Big Brothers Big
Sisters as well and one of the things
that I learned through that is just how
important it is when you first are
matched with somebody in a mentorship
role to be available to just show up and
I think that especially when you get new
teammates new people reporting to you
specifically like it's so important in
the beginning to just show up to just be
available
absolutely I see Patrick you have your
hand raised do you want to jump in
thanks Rachel yeah I'd be happy to and
Jesse thank you for doing this uh and I
I've just absolutely loved everything
you've said so far so this is this is
really good uh I have a question for you
about about that prioritizing you know
blocking time on your on your calendar
and prioritizing the the mentoring part
of your role uh I completely agree I
tried to do the same thing
um and I'm not sure if you're
responsible for like you know billing
hours and things like that exactly but
uh I'm just wondering about how how do
you how do you explain that up right how
do you how do you say well I you know I
don't have time to do this particular
project because I need to protect my
time for taking care of my staff a bit
and again I'm not trying to question
that approach I think that's exactly
right I'm just wondering how you justify
it I guess
um I'm gonna go back to the beginning of
my presentation I'm in a very very
fortunate role where
I have a small team and we make huge
business impact Financial impact on the
company's bottom line and actually
believe it or not it it's really it's
it's quite an advantage for me because
one I don't have billable hours to deal
with and two the impact that my team has
the impact of what certain projects
um how certain products can benefit the
company I think does give me a little
bit more power than most people in a
typical senior manager role with a new
team at a large corporation like this
maybe necessarily would all have
starting out where I can push back and
say listen this project this is a you
know
250 million dollar annual contract that
we're working on right now
this is our main priority and this is
why it's important and I don't really
honestly have to you know with my
leaders especially like they know the
value and so I don't have to push them
so hard all the time I do have to be
proactive I can't just start canceling
meetings that are on my calendar every
week you know the day of I have to be
proactive about okay here are the days
and times that I am trying to be
consistently available
trying my best and it's not easy but
trying my best to manage across many
many stakeholders not necessarily just
the ones who you know have all of the
financial impact but necessarily there's
a lot of Operational Support that my
team needs to provide deadlines that we
need to manage and it is tricky but I
think that in terms of priorities I do
have a bit of an advantage where just
the value is very clear there's some
operational things that I have to manage
into my timeline but usually we have a
lot of you know lead time a lot of
awareness of what those deadlines are
that makes it a little bit easier to
manage so not a great answer other than
you know I think I'm a little bit
fortunate on that front thank you Jess
you know that that really is helpful and
you know just uh recognizing the need to
plan and build that into schedules going
forward is is really a useful answer and
so I do appreciate that I'll just say
that uh you might be in a fortunate spot
but you're in a fortunate spot because
you deliver value right so you deserve
some credit for the fortunate spot
you're in
thanks I'll take it definitely yeah and
showing being able to show that Roi that
that your team provides too
I see I think Catherine you had a
similar question I think you said maybe
was answered in that but just want to
double check if there's anything you
wanted to follow up in that question too
yeah no I think that was a great answer
Jesse and and yeah you are in a fortune
fortunate position and Patrick you're
absolutely right you deserve to have
that fortune
um I was going to ask a follow-up
question but it looks to me like Frank
has asked the question so I I throw the
floor open to Frank I love it we're all
on the same page here Frank you want to
jump in yeah
um the thing about being proactive like
just you said that you can't cancel a
bunch of meetings like at the start of
the day and make decisions and kind of
jam everybody up can you talk about any
of the tools that you use for
communication whether it's within your
team whether it is
um what I say managing like managing
your calendars I don't know maybe it's
Google or Outlook that's the standard
um and then of course communicating
insights like how do you think about
communication and can you talk about any
of the tools that you use that might be
different than your typical Zoom slack
Outlook stack
yeah I actually I've tried so many tools
and the thing that I recently have kind
of circled back to is just trying to
keep the simple stupid you know what I
mean so like it is mostly Outlook there
was a plug-in I hope we don't have
anyone from Microsoft that I'll offend
here but I tried some Microsoft plugins
I think there was something called Viva
that would like block Focus time on my
calendar and it was constantly getting
like overlapped with other meetings and
just like not a convenience like 15
minutes here 20 minutes there and like
that's not a good way especially coding
that's not a good way to work so I ended
up just kind of
literally I planned it like a month
ahead of time where I okay for this
month it is what it is I'll manage how I
can I'm going to you know reply
tentative to the meetings that I don't
have to be at unless somebody is in the
invite saying this is what I need you
here in this meeting to do I'll reply
tentative
um and you know if I'm available then
I'm available and if not then you know I
might have something more urgent that
needs my attention during that time
but it was like literally a month ahead
of time okay
the Viva thing wasn't working I'm gonna
block a big chunk on Mondays Wednesdays
and Fridays of like heads down this is
the time that I'm available
my employees know that that time is I am
available and everybody else on my
Outlook Calendar sees me as busy
um and then I make sure that I leave
open time so people do have time to
schedule meetings otherwise they'll just
start overlapping with other things so
it's really just trying to you know a
big part of it is really just
learning how to say no politely and so
like replying tentative and if somebody
reaches like hey can you make it just
being able to very politely and nicely
say sure I think I can make time but can
you help me understand like what you
need my input on so that I can come
prepared things like that where it's
just like
and I think just like letting people
know that my time is not endlessly
limitly you know Limitless in terms of
like I can be available whenever
um and just kind of like setting an
expectation that
what can I help with and do you need me
there and maybe I can send somebody else
or maybe I don't need to be on this one
but I need to be on the next one and so
it's just kind of
planning ahead and you know in the
moments just kind of being able to say
no nicely I think
it's really helpful and yeah sorry I was
gonna say on the tooling front yeah it's
really just Outlook at this point
um I use jira mostly for project
management but it's really mostly just
Outlook and um and teams so teams chat
teams meetings yeah cool
that's helpful from the other
perspective too like thinking about the
person scheduling the meeting to make
sure that it's very clear in the meeting
invite when I ask people to join or if I
put them maybe as optional so they know
about it that they know what their role
and that might be
I see Alan you asked a question in the
chat you want to jump in
yeah I'm just finding all the right
buttons
um yeah hi Jesse um I think my question
is kind of bouncing off what you
mentioned about operational
responsibilities and I think that makes
me curious if you can speak a little bit
more about kind of the breadth of things
that your team does and thinking of
operationally specifically if if you
have any challenging balances of that
work versus other work and in turn then
how you if that influences the way that
you describe roles on your team knowing
that you've got you know a mix of
responsibilities or if you find that you
have people who are really specialized
and they they fit in those niches really
well
um so yeah that's a little bit of the
sort of day-to-day and kind of big
particular you know work of the team
that I'm really curious about
yeah so I think like our I think I
mentioned a little bit but our big
priority is really kind of predicting
okay we have these contracts that are
expiring in the next 12 to 15 months
it's coming up with some you know we
have like an analytics Suite that you
know me and my team have developed
um which basically predicts how many
customers would you know churn Drop
video if we were to lose specific
programming
um it does a lot of additional like
analytics in terms of Just descriptives
Around what are the popular programs
what is the seasonality Baton is like
how much do people consume this but then
going Beyond tonnage like what do people
actually care about you know we really
see that you know people's passion is
with you know are you tuning live to
like House of the Dragon you probably
care a ton if you're watching that
literally at like 9 pm sharp compared to
okay you just binged you know
the last uh
I don't know eight season of friends or
something you know what I mean like it's
just different types of the total hours
might be the same but it's not all equal
so I really enjoy that part of it we
spent a big part of our time
producing that report uh answering
additional follow-up questions about you
know specific programming there's a ton
of um
you know different like nuances with
programming and viewing and what people
care about so that's a big priority but
a lot of our other you know operational
responsibilities line okay we have this
contract that's expiring and even if
we're not planning to drop the content
we have to be prepared legally for if
that situation were to happen where we
don't come to terms and so we have to
have you know lists you know
strategic analytics my team
traditionally does not like to do a lot
of operational text we're really tasks
we're focused on strategy but viewing
that is incredibly sensitive so it's
really just my team that has access to
it and so we do have to sometimes fill
in a lot of operational roles in terms
of preparing making sure that the call
centers know how many calls they should
expect if we are to go dark on some
programming make sure that they have all
of the customers you know in the system
tagged as like these are the heavy
viewers of this these are the passionate
folks that you should be aware of
um you know app users if that were to go
dark so like some of that kind of you
know even we you know we have a lot of
like legal responsibilities in terms of
like Public Access channels and making
sure that we can provide the legal team
with certain information about you know
what is the viewership of Public Access
television and things like that which is
not necessarily strategic it's it's
required and like we consider that to be
operational
um
it's just it's necessary and because
viewing data is so sensitive my team is
kind of responsible for for most of that
as well like I said usually we have a
lot of lead time with that and so we can
kind of plan and we've really in my team
invested a lot in what can we automate
as much as we can you know take tasks
that we do multiple times and just make
it reproducible and as light touch as
possible we've kind of invested in in
making sure that we can do that easily
efficiently and you know with as little
time effort as possible
cool it's a it's a domain I don't know
anything about so it's fascinating to
hear like lots of activities that are
familiar but in a completely different
you know area of knowledge and expertise
um uh so thank you yeah really really
fascinating thanks yeah just to follow
up a little bit too on your you know how
you actually like I think I forget
exactly maybe you can help me understand
what the question was but like find
Talent OR tailor the role to the
expectations I think you had mentioned
what was it yeah okay sort of the sort
of that balance of of
um you know like analytical versus
operational it sounds like maybe it's
not as much of a dilemma for you because
so much of it sounds at least a lot of
it sounds like it's maybe similar
activities but in different kinds of of
um like subject areas or or maybe
domains
um but yeah I was curious if that was if
that was a challenge for describing your
role and being able to reliably give the
work that you described in the job ads
to to the folks on your team
I I still think it's the big challenge I
am up front with people that you know
this is the part of the job that we have
to do but if you're somebody who likes
doing a lot of different kinds of things
which you do have to do in this role
again I think because the viewing guide
is so you know um
um you know Limited in terms of access
you know a lot of times people on this
team have to do you know wear a lot of
hats in terms of engineer developer you
know like really look at things in terms
of creative problem solving because you
don't necessarily have the same
resources as you would on a team that
has data that's you know just available
to everyone
um
so as long as people like to do
different kinds of things and again I
think that you know I try to kind of
phrase it a little bit more like yes we
have these operational tasks
um
but one of the things that I personally
enjoy and I look for people who you know
also enjoy like how do I spend as little
time and effort on that part as possible
how can I write it our function a
package and our markdown report whatever
it may be to just like get this done
as quickly and easily as possible and
not spend my time just doing copy and
paste type coding nobody wants to do
that well yeah hopefully the people I'm
looking for don't really want to do that
over and over again right that's great
thank you yeah thank you I just have to
ask is there a show that you've been
really surprised that people care a lot
about
oh gosh most reality TVs like well this
one
um
there's quite a few shows
um
even like you'd be surprised how many
much people watch you know sometimes
like the old westerns are still very
very popular you know things like that
you know even like friends like
um those old shows that just kind of
have that you know popularity like the
amount of time that people go back to it
and watch it and spend all those things
is always a little bit like wow that's
that's shocking yeah that's interesting
I see um Tiffany you asked the question
there's a star so I'll read it but it
it's what is your typical schedule do
you have times when you are trying to
meet a deadline and have to work more
hours in a week or do you have a good
work-life balance
it's definitely gotten a lot better
since I've gotten my team together so
for a while I was kind of working
independently on this
um like the you know content negotiation
content acquisition support I was
working relatively independently on it
and so you know sometimes there would be
like an actual hard deadline not like a
soft deadline but like this contract is
expiring in a week or two weeks and we
need this information and sometimes I
did
work late or work a weekend or something
like that or wake up at like you know
three in the morning and get like an
early start because I work too much the
day before and
um
a lot of that is honestly like
I think that's just like how I am like I
sometimes like I get curious to the
point where it's like no I am going to
solve this maybe something has gone
wrong like a server has gone down or
like you know um a cluster has gone down
or something has happened and I'm like
I'm going to get this finished like
I think something that really helped me
in my career is just kind of taking
ownership of this project and really
kind of like I am going to deliver no
matter what obstacles come in my way and
even though I think my leadership
would have been much more understanding
if I would have said hey there's this
blocker this isn't going to get done I
know I would have had support I think
there's like something wrong with my
brain that just like no you're gonna get
this done it's a stubbornness that I
don't know is great but I think that now
that I have a team that you know we have
multiple people working on this it's a
lot easier for us I think to kind of
spread the workload around and I think
I'm a lot more protective of my people's
time than I am of my own I started to
realize that it's the same thing like I
need to approach it in the same way but
um my work-life balance I'd say
in the last three to six months has
actually really really gotten to a good
a really good spot
it's great to hear it's nice
I see Brittany you asked a great
question in the chat do you want to jump
in
sure yeah um so to give you a little bit
of context on my question I'm an analyst
and what I'm trying to do is sort of
help tool up other analysts on my team
so a lot of analysts use things like SQL
power bi those kinds of tools and I've
really seen a great need for maybe some
like more Programming type tools like
Python and R and things like that
um but of course as an analyst when
you're working with business partners
you're just trying to deliver you know
value and insights
um in a speedy way right you're trying
to do it as quickly as possible and so
I'm trying to sort of convince analysts
maybe even take a little bit of a step
back and learn and Implement something
new that can help them both them and
their business partners in the future
but I'm trying to kind of balance those
two things so do you have any advice for
how I as the person trying to sort of
get these things up and running can help
to create more of that culture of let's
go ahead and take a step back and do
something now that will help me in the
long term versus just trying you know
check boxes as quickly as possible
it is
a constant battle and I feel like it is
the place where like it requires some
strategy because you can't do it all the
time
you have to like really I think
recognize when is the right time to
pounce on an idea you have to have the
ideas sometimes you have to sit on them
for a little while and then you have to
just be able to like recognize I think
that opportunity and sometimes it's okay
to make mistakes like sometimes you push
something too soon and you know it might
hurt a little bit but don't let that
kill your motivation
um I hate PowerPoint like I hate coffee
and paste so much I might have said
coffee and paste like 80 times already I
hope I didn't but I hate it and for a
long time you know some of the reports
that I was doing like just to give you
an example Paramount is like 30
individual networks and so sometimes
we're repeating views for you know 30
networks times like you know five
different views or something at a bare
minimum it's too many slides too much
copy and paste and I had made a you know
push for oh we should convert this to
mark down or shiny or something and same
thing it's like well our stakeholders
don't know how to use that and like it's
a server it's you know very private and
for data private customer information
and covid hits and sports viewing kind
of just went away there's like covet hit
pandemic hit and we had so many
questions coming in about what do we do
what's going on what are customers doing
what are they watching you know it's all
sports just kind of went you know
completely off the air immediately and I
really was like this is my moment I
created a you know this is back we were
in Hadoop at the time we've since moved
but um we were in Hadoop at the time I
set up some like shell scripts like that
scripts to you know run at certain days
and like scheduled it and like created
this like pipeline that I had been
messing around with for a while created
an automated our markdown report
and basically I was able to give the
information that the business was asking
for very very quickly
and they learn how to use it because
it's like they really wanted it and it
would have been too much for my very
small team to be reporting every single
week on like what is happening this week
it'd be a huge load on our team to do
that
every single week from scratch and so
basically
kind of investing and I I will admit
that I spent a little bit of night you
know time on this project
um but it was a passion project where I
was like all right this is my moment to
prove that like this is a feasible
solution and show because we had so many
questions coming in this was one of a
huge backlog questions I was able to
show that okay this is done we've
automated we can use this for other
things for other questions that business
owners want every single week for data
that they want every single week and
still have time left over for those ad
hoc questions those one-off things that
are really important we'll have time for
that too and not miss the report
and so I think there's just this kind of
strategy that you have to really kind of
always be thinking about of when is the
right moment to
you know maybe not necessarily ask for
approval to just do something
and show the value
and hopefully you have leaders who will
support you in those decisions if it's
the right one in the right moments
um
because that's really I think that's
that that's what I've been able to those
I think like little windows that I found
to be able to kind of push some of the
different tools that you know were not
really I think supported in the
beginning of my career here
awesome thank you
I absolutely love that that answer too
thank you
um I'm just going through to see some of
the questions over from slido too but
Timmy Timothy I see you asked the
question in the chat do you want to jump
in
hmm yeah sorry I'm just unmuting
everything uh yeah so it sounds like
you're doing really interesting work
over there
um and you if in my imagination you have
a suite of like dozens or hundreds of
apps and reports some of which are
mission critical and all that are you do
you have like a unit testing group or QA
QC
process dedicated process or or is it
sort of just fix it when it breaks
um so my team does it actually we do in
Enterprise business intelligence have a
reporting team
um because the viewing data is sensitive
you know sometimes my team gets into
that especially with the content
acquisition work those those contracts
are also considered very sensitive and
information so I um you know some some
of that is like exclusive to my team and
we kind of like again I think I said
like my team wears a lot of different
hats like sometimes we get into the
engineering space sometimes and get into
the data quality space A lot of times we
do even get into the reporting space the
coveted report that was the solution
that fit the question at the time we
didn't continue to support that
if that were to continue to be a you
know solution that needed to be out
there not that needed to be out there
every week for business owners it would
actually transition to another team in
EDI the reporting team so we do have you
know a whole team that of management
um who does more data quality work and
unit testing and
um you know typical reporting um things
like that which you know we don't take a
lot of ownership necessarily on my team
for
um
long-term reporting or data assets or
anything like that we try to just be
good partners honestly with that team
you know if we can solve something and
hand it off you know we try to do that
if we can collaborate and get a solution
together that has some business impacts
we try to do that but we don't normally
you know strategic analytics really is
more focused on you know these are the
questions that the presidents and BPS in
the company are asking
how can we answer them and then once it
becomes more of a you know even like a
model for example we might build a
segmentation in strategic analytics but
when it's time for deployment you know
we might hand that over to the data
science team to actually you know get
into a good deployment
um you know every month or week whatever
it may be
awesome thank you yeah
thank you I wanted to Circle back to
um Brittany's question too on a culture
of learning because I see there were a
lot a few comments in the the chat that
I missed as well
um from both Hugh and Marlene so I was
curious if either of you wanted to jump
in as well
Arlene it looks like you you mentioned
you're starting a group to unite data
scientists yeah
yeah hi Rachel um first of all thank you
to this group um not just the speakers
but although thank you Jesse I just um I
found all the input that I've been
getting from you
um I've been here for about a month
doing these Hangouts really invaluable
so it's nice also just for the
solidarity and some of the same issues
we're getting but I just want you all to
know that your your opinions and your um
experience matters even to people like
me
um so anyway I'm thank you that's
awesome yeah it really does make a
difference so I hope you give yourself a
pat on the back for that um and you too
yeah so at literally as of yesterday I
finally got the green light from rco
Otis start a data scientist and analyst
group
um Jesse I'm taking all these mental
notes as you speak about you know kind
of like some of the management and
whatnot I not I'm not an official
manager of these people but there's a
lot of disparate systems and
um workflows in the organization we
don't have a common like data warehouse
or single source of Truth we're a family
of companies there's seven companies and
we're all over the place so part of this
group is a to figure out what people are
doing
um but also much to Brittany's Point
like how do you get them to step back
from the the hustle and bustle of
checking boxes being more of like a
compliance-minded I'm trying to just get
these things done for my boss into a
little more of a proactive mindset right
a little more
um intentional I would say and
um we're we're going to have these
groups are going to be broken up into
what I call Show and Tell modules well
they'll somebody will literally just be
able to come up and say this is what
I've done in power bi it doesn't have to
be anything fancy we just need to know
for transparency sake what people are
doing
um and then we'll also have learning
sessions where somebody who feels like
they have at least a periphery knowledge
of a software or a tool or a programming
language can show other people what it
what's capable of and what they've
utilized it for
um so as far as the time allocation for
that
um and Jesse I hear you especially when
you're like okay I have to make sure I'm
not so booked that I can't talk to my
team right I'm very fortunate that my
schedule is fairly flexible and I keep a
certain block of time available in the
morning I'm going to make that open to
the group to let them ping me for
questions but also just to connect them
with somebody else in the group who's
much more knowledgeable on what they
need than I am right
um and I think right now we're shooting
for every other week Brittany so you
know one hour every other week if that's
not doable then there's something very
very wrong with their management right
and I'm also willing to go to bat and
start you know duking it out with
managers if I need to in a polite and
political way but that that there's no
reason for anybody at any job to be
you know eight hours a day nose to the
to the
um or puddle to the metal just inundated
with work right there's something wrong
with how you're allocating your hours
and if you don't have room for
improvement and or skill management or
skill Improvement then you're going to
be stuck in this rut and that's when I'm
unhappy employees leave so I want to
avoid that it's partially why I started
this group so there's my my Spiel but
thanks for the opportunity
thanks
that's great and way to go on on
starting the group too I know Lisa um
you mentioned you started a group as
well I'm curious if you want to to share
a little bit about what you're doing
sure
um so I work at Blue Cross Blue Shield
of Minnesota and I started in January
and I found it
um as much as I love being remote
um it was really hard to like get to
know where all the sort of
I don't know data and analytics folks
lived especially the ones outside of the
data and analytics sort of larger team
um so I essentially just like as I
started meeting people was like
I'm going to do these meetups and I'm
going to invite you right and
um so kind of started with this random
group
of like people I happen to have met
um and then just recently
um started inviting all of data and
analytics so like 150 people
um plus all the people I know who are
outside of that group and what's been
forwarded to
um and and kind of like Marlene was
saying um
have used a lot of those ideas so
um we've done a couple talks about data
visualization
um we actually had uh marav who just
talked here maybe a couple months ago uh
come speak to the group that was really
cool
um
so I've done some sort of teaching type
things and then um I am going to have
people start sort of sharing their
projects as well
yeah it's been great so far I love it
I love all this focus on you know
teaching and learning it's awesome
that's great yeah kudos to everybody who
who's leading those groups too I know
it can be a bit of extra work too and so
it's nice to be able to to celebrate
them as well I I see our first actual
anonymous question too so I just wanted
to remind people if you do want to ask
anything anonymously you can use the
slido too but somebody asked it's been
in the news that Netflix will start to
crack down on password sharing soon have
you tried to estimate this problem for
Comcast streaming services
I have not looked at that I am also I've
been tracking that a little bit I'm
curious I know there was some um I think
they might have uh started that in some
other countries and I think they had
some
they're starting to slow down on on new
connects from what I understand overall
so
um
early information suggest that it could
be bad for Netflix I don't know what the
impact on Comcast necessarily will be
um
I have not been asked that one yet but I
imagine I'm going to get that one soon
so thanks for the heads off I might have
to start looking into that early
all right
um I see you also put a question in the
chat you want to jump in
sure yeah I think you've just already
touched on this slightly but um just
curious about your you know workflow
management you know how your data teams
work how they sort of collaborate I know
you've touched on this but just just
curious about your methodology and um
you know how you uh just recently
uh joined booking.com and we have like
new intake and planning processes in
place and it's just
um just really curious um how are you
going to do it
yeah I love talking about workflow so
um just from a like where does work come
from standpoint like going to like the
very very very beginning
um we actually don't have a jira intake
for us so it's not like anybody can just
submit a request and then all requests
are treated equally we you know
strategic analytics like sometimes I
described as like the internal
Consultants of Comcast you know like we
are in the meetings with you know the
president of content acquisition you
know the president of you know products
of different Services of customer
experience like literally we are in all
of those meetings and so we are able to
kind of hear what are the questions that
are being repeated over and over again
where's the value that's kind of like on
my team to figure out what is the
biggest value that we can add right now
what's most important and we do get
specific questions that we have to
answer but really the work is not coming
from like a jeera intake or anything
like that it's coming from you know the
highest the business
um you know decision makers throughout
the company and
so that's kind of like how work gets
prioritized and then basically my team
you know we have most of the viewing
data is in we just moved recently to AWS
our dad is an S3 storage
um not all of it you know like most big
companies you know there's data in many
many places and we have to join you know
cloud and on-prem and bring everything
together and
you know we do a lot of engineering to
kind of set up you know jobs that run
you know every month or so and so that
we have that available and ready to go
for some of the reports that we do and
basically we'll do a bunch of
aggregation in you know databricks for
example in a data Works notebook with
scholar
um or you know maybe some spark or
something like that and then basically
you know write out some um data and then
from our pull that data in run the
reports my team has recently started
working I think I mentioned before that
I kind of was doing this mostly
independently for a while
and so when I started working as a team
I was really excited to finally have the
chance like we're gonna work from a repo
like everything is in the GitHub repo
we're all like working you know we
started off just on like GitHub desktop
honestly and you know just working from
the same
repository all together at once it's
just like such a fun experience and of
course I messed up one of my I messed up
the first one the first process of
course which I actually felt really good
that I was like okay both of my you know
new teammates did awesome I screwed it
up and I got to kind of be the person
who you know made an example of what not
to do and kind of communicate that so I
I had such a fun time with that uh
that's kind of my new
I think passion is just like making sure
that we all have like a good solid repo
that we're using proper Version Control
and you know contributing in that way
because I just think it's such a better
workflow honestly than what had been
doing beforehand even though I was using
packages and trying to kind of like
standardize and make all of my code
reproducible it's different when you're
doing it on a team and I will say like
if you haven't had that experience it's
definitely
you know uh scary but in a very good way
that's very interesting yeah thank you
very much
thank you I'm curious how you like share
those lessons of failure across the the
team too
with a big smile usually laughing yeah
just like of course it was me you know
how to have fun with it like it is a
learning experience
um
I think when I was earlier in my career
I was always so nervous of making a
mistake especially publicly or God
forbid like as a manager with people who
reported to me it seemed like such a
scary thing and I don't know if it's
just like years on the job if it's just
like the result of doing it many times
um I don't know if it's just that I
don't really have a good sense of like
why I've kind of grown out of that but I
have grown out of that to the point
where it's
you know
I guess maybe it's just like having
enough successes under your belt and
having a reputation that you can you
know stand firm on
um maybe that's just it but I definitely
feel a lot of
um psychological safety I guess to kind
of fail fail publicly and
you know hopefully nothing really really
bad has happened luckily I don't work in
medicine or anything where like lives
are on the line thankfully that's not
the case so you know mistakes happen I
think that it's a good learning
opportunity
as long as it's not everything that you
do and you have a reputation as somebody
who can deliver and you know isn't
constantly making big mistakes I don't
think you need to worry so much about it
that's not the thing that usually from
what I've learned that's not the thing
that people remember forever about you
yeah so definitely accepting it
eventually
I remember on seeing on Twitter that in
the like data Community there's this
thing called I think data mishaps night
and a bunch of people just share these
kind of stories with each other as well
um
I just lost my track of what I was going
to ask you let me let me think of what I
was what I was saying oh I was gonna say
um so moving into the new like into
people management
I imagine you have to think a lot more
about hiring and growing a team so I'm
curious like any Lessons Learned there
in terms of of hiring and interviewing
people
yeah I'm still learning a lot of those
lessons I think I have been doing some
hiring and interviewing and it can be
very difficult I think to you know in
such a quick you know 30 minute
interview or so like really get to know
a person
um not just like in terms of other
technical skills but
um it is really really really hard I
think to like look at a resume and to
necessarily you know get a good sense of
like is this the right fit I think
whenever possible you know just trying
to be more involved with the community
and have that kind of you know if you're
not involved with our lady cilia I'll
give a shout out to our latest Philly
that's a great place to get involved
even like the r Studio conference
um there's like lots of ways where I
think I've been able to benefit from
just already being in a community you
know I haven't necessarily
um had anything quite worked out yet you
know in terms of hiring from somebody
I've met through any of those events but
I do think that just being involved like
that is you know I don't know if it's
gonna work yet but that's my strategy
right now it's just kind of like some of
the other things at my you know in my
career just trying to take ownership of
okay I'm not going to leave it all up to
the process that exists in a large
company right I'm not going to leave it
all up to the recruiters on my team
necessarily I'm going to take some
ownership and you know get involved and
talk to people and just kind of make
those connections and trust that
eventually
that's going to be you know a real
benefit for hiring for me and my team
that's great thank you I see Phil you
asked a question
um I can read it for you it's it's I'd
like to hear more about how your
strategic analytics group or role was
formed was it organic growth from your
solo work or did Comcast open a new role
or position
so good question
um strategic analytics so Enterprise
business intelligence at Comcast I think
is like seven or eight years old it's
not that old it's relatively new it
started with I think like 12 people or
something
there's some some folks who can give you
a better history lesson than me honestly
I'll have to refresh but
um we grew really really fast and one of
the big wins this is before I was here
just to just to call that out but before
I was here one of the big early wins
that we had
was actually this kind of work that I'm
doing now it's getting access to the
viewing data was a big win getting
involved with the president of content
acquisition and building that
relationship was a huge win where we
were able to very early in my
departments
um history like show a huge value to the
organization I've made a lot of changes
to like you know this this type of work
that we do the type of analytics that we
do it's changed a lot since I started
like five years ago
um but in general what happened was
basically I was doing this content
acquisition support as well as a bunch
of other video and content support
and my manager was a very very good
Mentor and him it was a team of three
him and the other woman that I started
working with on the team they went and
started their own team in the same
Department in strategic analytics where
they are completely focused on training
new hires on giving them a you know
cross-training across all the different
groups in
strategic analytics and so basically
that kind of led me into this role where
okay now I am leading the video and
content team
and doing all of that support and kind
of starting my own team from scratch
maybe not from scratch yeah and how and
how big is the team now did you study in
the beginning
I have two people right now and I am
looking for one more
oh awesome all right so you're hiring
now feel free to share the link to the
role in the the chat as well
yeah would it what is that position that
you're hiring for now
senior analyst
awesome I can try and grab it in the the
background as well and put it into the
chat
um I also just want to
double check that I haven't missed
anybody's question from the chat or
slido so feel free to just like jump in
or raise your hand here as well
give people a few seconds here
foreign
I know you were talking about like being
intentional about building the culture
on your team and like sharing data
across separate teams as well and like
I can't remember the the exact phrase
but around knowledge sharing so I was
just curious like do the different teams
within Comcast like get together to
share projects with each other as well
and like teach each other how you're
you're solving problems
yeah we do do projects together pretty
frequently a lot of times will team up
so you know we have like a finance team
in my department and selling a lot of
pencil team with the finance team
we actually just created a new team
called Channel analytics coming out of
the collaboration between the product
side and the finance side
um so we do a lot of you know whenever
we can collaboration sometimes it's
within strategic analytics so like the
domains where it's you know product
Finance customer experience all of those
things there's a lot of collaboration
that happens there especially even code
sharing where it's like hey I'm doing
this project and it touches your domain
can we just like do some code reviews
and talk about you know am I on the
right path am I thinking about this
right what do you know about you know
your domain expertise that could help me
with this analysis and then yeah
sometimes it does kind of develop into a
whole new team a whole new line of work
that we need to focus on and you know
that's the thing that happens pretty
frequently for pretty large company
cool I see there was an anonymous
question I know we have a few minutes
left here and one was do you have to
handle salary negotiations in the
interview process or do you leave that
to HR and they were wondering like does
it turn you off if somebody like asks
for more
it doesn't turn me off I will say that I
I most of that is on HR most of that is
not on me specifically it's on um folks
that are in HR and you know
it is some of it is defined by the
budget that is defined by my team and by
Finance not just like my Department's
Finance team but like overall Comcast
Finance team but for the most part
um I do not handle too much of the
salary negotiations myself thankfully I
I'm very thankful for that actually
and doesn't always sound like like a fun
part of it
um Marlene I see you also asked a
question in the chat you want to jump in
sure yeah the question is just around
this one is still a struggle for me
Jesse is documentation right because
there's always the Handover to new
employees and you can't remember what
the old employee had in place or why
it's there or when you're implementing
something new everybody's really excited
and guns ablazing to get infrastructure
up and running right all those pipelines
and whatnot but then how do you handle
documentation making sure people follow
through with that that the document that
the metadata as well documented as well
just wanted to get your thoughts on that
yeah my team I'm fortunate my team is
small and because we don't have too much
ownership of like the actual data as a
you know data product like the viewing
data necessarily we don't have to stress
documentation too much I do try to just
like be better especially working as a
team I'll be honest I was terrible when
I was working mostly independently I've
been trying to be a lot better now just
like having a team working as a team
commenting code
um you know pushing updates to GitHub
every time I make any updates things
like that but in terms of like actual
documentation of workflows
we don't do too much of that on my team
I think that's a it's a huge amount of
overhead and we're more focused really
on being
fast and effective and when there's
larger products larger projects over a
longer period of time
um honestly just making sure that it's
reproducible less so than documented
because not it's not like anybody can
come in and access the viewing data
that's you know not something everyone
can do
so we haven't yet grown to the point
where that's really important for us to
spend our time on
Brittany I see you just commented into
the chat too if you want to jump in
I like the idea of this documenting
party
yeah I'd
um so like my team we've got like five
analysts or a little bit of a smaller
team but one idea that I've always kind
of floated around with is like doing
something like that I know that I tried
to do that even in just my own General
workflow of like Fridays or really more
cleanup days than anything
um but I haven't really tried it with
the team where we all kind of get
together and we document and we show
each other our code especially I think
that's helpful because as the person
writing the code sometimes it's hard to
know like what to comment and what not
to
um but this is like another kind of hey
we're all in this together we've all got
to do this
um and making it a little bit more fun
rather than like oh you have to do your
code and get otherwise you're horrible
terrible whatever so
yeah but I can let you guys know how
that goes if
if it goes well if it doesn't go well
just I'll keep you all updated
yeah one thing I guess we do have a you
know a blog post that we have internally
that is you know hosted through I think
GitHub pages but we do you know if we
figure out like a new way to move I
think I saw a question come in the chat
about like are you in the cloud or local
and one of the things you got to figure
out when we moved to databricks is okay
how do we move data from you know uh
Cloud location to an on-prem location
and so we figured out how to do that and
then you know just kind of like writing
a script that's well commented posting
it on the blog sharing it around with
the team so like things that do impact
you know more throughout the
organization we do try to kind of put
some documentation together for that and
post it on the blog post right now is
kind of the place where we're putting it
it's been GitHub before it can be a very
casual you know
hey look I did this thing if anybody is
interested I'm gonna go at lunch or you
know Fridays same thing as like Friday's
Easter birthday for kind of sharing
information on Friday I'm gonna like you
know show everybody how I did this so it
can be pretty
you know posted on the blog or a little
bit more of a casual thing
awesome I know we just set the top of
the hour and a few people have to to run
um but I think you just answered
Javier's question there and that most of
what your team's doing is in the cloud
today
we do some stuff locally at the last
step for some reports where we're
pulling in data from the cloud
it's already aggregated most of the
processing happens in the cloud but
sometimes we do use our local car every
once in a while
thank you so much Jesse it's been really
fun getting to learn about the ways
Comcast is using data and also how
you're building that culture and showing
value on the team
um if people wanted to connect with you
I did share like that our ladies Philly
group in the chat but is LinkedIn the
best place to connect with you
Our Ladies Philly Twitter
all of those are good okay awesome well
thank you so much really appreciate it
and thank you everybody for all the
great questions too I feel like there
was so much energy here today really
really appreciate you all being here
we'll be back next week and we'll be
joined by Marcos Huerta manager of data
science at Carmax as well so hope to see
you then bye everybody thank you Rachel